taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two foods gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
welcome to taste buds
hello i stepped on you it's okay do it
is that ready maybe leave it in heaven
go
hey good go welcome to taste buds you're
the taste buddies and we're the taste
buds i'm joe derosa i'm savilicano and
today we got a hot one why don't you
launch that debate onto twitter from now
on we're gonna hit twit it's out tweet
is out
tweet's already out the debate of today
is already out to twitter
we're not gonna tell you just yet what
it is
but we'll give you a hint
uh it's
uh delicious
it's uh heartwarming
uh and i think probably unhealthy huh go
ahead i don't want to knock any
potential sponsors no you know don't get
me wrong
you're right
and it is i mean it's delicious i mean
there's no doubt i mean we're not
knocking any with anybody look what i'm
sure what i'm trying to get at is what
i'm really i'm kind of beating around
the bush here is
i am coming off the heels of of just a
glorious victory
it's it's it's you're right it's a
sweeter victory than a trouncing yes
i'm coming off the heels of just a
glorious victory where i won by 0.1
and it just feels so good
but here's what excites me right now i
could be more invested in this debate
we're about to have than i've been in
any debate we've had
i mean that really i mean that and
i think this one could be
just as close i think there's a chance
i think it's real i agree with you we've
seen in the past where there were
powerhouses that took a like a rate you
know what we forgot we always forget to
say
eat the humble pie segment we think it's
very clever no we say it but we forget
like we forgot it last episode no we
don't
oh okay but every time you pick up the
phone we say it's humble pie we did in
last episode are you sure i swear
okay all right you know at the end we
think it's so clever that what we did
just like we think the name taste buds
is clever it is clever you know but uh
at the end at the end the segment's
called humble pie because someone's
wrong and has to eat it yeah but uh
anyway but we we've seen in the humble
pie segment where powerhouses like
that you thought
would like topple kings and nations went
down
and pretty handily by five percent
that's she
go down was like seeing it was like i
remember when i was 12 years old and i
saw tyson get knocked out
oh yeah by busted douglas yeah you
weren't 12. you had to be older than
that
i was probably 12 13. is that how old
you are
yeah dude like mike tyson's mike tyson
didn't lose to buster douglas 30 years
ago
dude we were like maybe 13 i was like in
the seventh or eighth grade when that
happens my friend i remember my friend
nikki marcelo was sleeping over that was
not when i was in high school wow we
were watching it 1999 30 years ago
exactly 30 years ago yeah you said 13 i
go mike tyson getting knocked out by
muscle that was 30 years ago it's 30
years ago to the year to the letter the
uh
but when i saw that happen i remember
being like i remember cheering that it
happened
and i was a huge tyson fan yeah because
you just can't a great underdog story
can't be beat yeah and you just didn't
think it was possible you couldn't
believe it happened well today
and we won't say it but today you are
playing
you are playing favor today and i am
playing underdog today
well i don't know actually i tell you
the truth i thought
no today
is this what we're about to do you don't
think you have the favorite i think this
is going to be real because there's no
there is no public betting odds prior to
the poll you have the favorite and i do
believe that i had the favorite in
orange juice versus apple juice and i
took an l i'm telling you though i don't
in this i mean it in this debate i think
this will be as close
there is a public rivalry between these
things yeah okay so what i was gonna say
was i think that you have the definite
favorite but i think this is could be a
you'd be surprised type of thing okay
yeah yeah okay i think that i definitely
uh i definitely i'm gonna make a case
and i think that what i'm going to say
is going to be a a
common thread for a lot of our our
listeners we're looking at pictures of
the stuff we're going to debate sounds
like the couch but i swear to god
i want to eat all of it i can't
it's it's
mike as you said it's triggering me
it's triggering me so much right now i
wanna and we might go get some of this
food later
and if we do i i'm gonna i'm in like
that place where i'm gonna spend like 30
dollars
you know what i mean yeah because i'm
just like i just want to make sure i can
get to anything i want at any moment are
you there right now that's how you
feeling
where i mean you're really i mean you
just ate
i know but
this just set me off dude really i
haven't had this stuff in so long and it
just set me off and i was craving it the
other day and i didn't get it and then i
saw it at the ferry station on my way
over and i didn't get it there's
something and i was like i wanted it but
i didn't so now it's like this is my
mouth is starting to water this is like
when you start thinking about dessert
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's true what
they say they say you know what i can
get to an ice cream soda yeah because
i've been thinking about it it's true
what they say about like there's some
type of weird addictive ingredient it's
got to be right
it's oh yeah we'll look that up god only
knows people are probably um already
putting the pieces together about what
today's
battle is
i think we've been very vague you think
we've we were hinting you said you want
to go get it and spend 30 dollars there
i just said it's very addictive it
doesn't mean anything
all right let's know let's review
limited evidence okay let's do it so
better fast food is what we're doing
today yes joe you'll be playing for
mcdonald's
mcdonald's is the
top dog
mcdonald's is the yankees mcdonald's is
chocolate
mcdonald's is is top dog tell them who
you're playing for now
don't hesitate well
well because
popular convention would think that i'm
going with burger king because burger
king it's like have we ever done coke
pepsi no
and you got me coke what are we talking
about here okay
honestly i wait do you think it's pepsi
no i choose coke too okay but i will
tell you this though i just
happen to choose coke
but i'm never disappointed with the
pepsi i don't drink a lot of soda i am
but but when i when i have a pepsi i'm
always like oh cool a pepsi because i
don't get that for some reason i choose
coke more or places carry coke more so i
actually don't necessarily
they both had great marketing campaigns
i like burger king but one of the things
i don't like about burger king is you
have to get pepsi
and it doesn't taste wild right it
doesn't taste as good yeah burger king
repeats on me a little bit
um but i do think that they
they put up more
like i feel like there's a consensus
that burger king's menu like
like if apples to apples like it's more
of a higher quality product at
mcdonald's for some reason um but you
would think i'd be playing burger king
it's the clown versus the king and
that's the battle i mean that really is
dave like that's like really right but
that well that was the battle that was
the battle but i am pivoting
and uh i'm my my favorite fast food
again we're talking east coast here i
don't want to hear you what do we do
i don't want to be dancing around i
don't want to hear about your in and
outs i don't want to hear about you in
and outs i don't want to hear about your
fat burgers i don't want anybody don't
and don't pull fast casual into it like
it's not a five guy shake shack thing
this is you know the small place drive
through when you were little that kind
of this is britney spears aguilera katy
perry we're going this is big dogs this
is big dogs but it's also not i'm just
saying like shake shack's big dog but
that's
that's a level that's that's the shake
shack is not fast casual i love shake
shack i love it it's not a big dog it it
it's not it doesn't even step into the
realm of this of this i'm going i'm
going my favorite fast food is wendy's
okay uh since i'm a little kid i just
think that like
they might we'll look this up we're
gonna you know what i like about our
podcast too
if i may you may
i like that we also
we forgot to say i still love you at the
end no no we
i mean it's like it's like 2 am sorry we
i like literally don't even know like i
was like
3 30
we did hey babe before this yeah it's
been here since high noon i don't even
know how you're still talking um no it's
actually i'm totally fine like today for
some reason i'm a little tired than
normal but but i'm good and this is this
is a hot one a hot charger it's gonna
have a lot of motivation but i also like
how we get
there's some education involved in this
podcast which i like it's not just us
ranting and raving and hemming and
hawing we really i do come away with
some stats and i so we are going to
visit state and i do believe at least as
far as east coast goes maybe even
globally wendy's is probably third in
sales
um i don't know where they are in
locations versus sales so i don't know
if they're technically really like the
people's third place
choice i think you're wrong i think
wendy's has taken uh second place
uh sales-wise
holy [ __ ] not even close wow hold on a
second mcdonald's is number one in which
we assumed
oh my god wendy's trailing behind
chick-fil-a oh this is above birthday
okay oh wow okay so mcdonald's and where
are we chewing on the u.s system-wide
sales in the millions are we getting a
dollar amount in there
uh
i don't see a dollar wow subway now
here's what bob holy [ __ ] subway has
doubt almost double the franchisee the
franchises that mcdonald's has here's
what bothers me though about this what
this chart starbucks doesn't count as a
fast food risk out of here subway
doesn't count as a fast food restaurant
out of here we're talking classic fast
food mcdonald's number two should be
taco bell instead of starbucks and then
subway then chick-fil-a then wendy's
well now this is also the the amount of
stores is blowing my balls off here
mcdonald's is hardy at
13229. this might be united states i'm
not sure no
system-wide
there's only thirteen thousand
mcdonald's doesn't don't you think there
would be more than that
america that's what i'm saying
i would think there'd be i would think
well there's 50 states so i mean that's
like
i don't know whatever that comes out to
20 per thousand
so
20 times 10
200
200 that's like 50 times 10 is 500 350
three it's 350 in every state i don't
know is it 350 in every state here hold
on hold on i'm doing this i mean this is
crazy though but here's here's thirteen
thousand
two two nine just put thirteen thousand
divided by fifty states yeah yeah 265
per state that seems so low to me
yeah i mean you can't take a piss
without in a wind without hitting a
mcdonald's
right okay so starbucks i would feel
like wendy's would have more than that
there's only
five thousand eight hundred wendy's how
can their country how can they compete
they have like like literally like like
8 000 less chains starbucks now that's
telling because starbucks only has 6 300
chains and they're coming in second
there's no way in revenue and the reason
that is too is because a cup of coffee
is seven dollars
so like they their markup is high
that can't be there's no way there's
only 6 300 starbucks in this country
there's no way
oh
that's what it is oh yeah 2018 company
units
that's what it is well total change in
units no no it's not go back
to that other one pimp
to the to the
look let's go back to what we just had
to begin with
uh
yeah so check this out if you look at
the last column it says
change
in units from 2017. they lost 122 units
so does that mean total
well there was 13 000
i don't know
look here's the thing okay let's get
into this let's get into it okay here's
the thing this is the point i'm getting
at with wendy's and burger king there is
a public feud between wendy's and in uh
mcdonald's now wendy's has basically
dedicated wendy's has basically
dedicated its entire twitter account to
[ __ ] on mcdonald's you told me this
i didn't know this yeah and they made a
rap mixtape dissing mcdonald's
and i got to tell you wendy's tweets
about mcdonald's are fire i mean really
it's eminem level disses
can we hear one
can we find one yeah just go to wendy's
how is mcdonald's responding to wendy's
are they ignorant
i mean mcdonald's doesn't need to
respond they're mcdonald's you know what
i'm saying it's just like yeah when the
tweets are as broken as the ice cream
machine wow
the ice cream wow 700 000 likes yeah i
mean wendy's they're coming in they're
coming in strong on twitter
uh
hey mcdonald's
hey mcdonald's heard the news happy
national frozen food day do you know the
frozen beef that's sticking around in
your chicken oh my god
holy [ __ ]
yeah they go after them dude they go
they completely completely okay so
wow
hey mcdonald's roast us
but you know mcdonald's is the queen
dude it's like it's you know it does
it's like be like beyonce responding to
uh uh
i don't know oh wait did wendy's trolls
shake shack
yeah that's cool so long as you
keep
leaving the delicious to us
uh over 30 minutes do people usually
have to wait that long with you guys wow
wendy's is a little [ __ ]
wendy's is like 50 cent dude just going
after everybody wow
i love it poor big mac stuck with frozen
beef wow
jesus dude well all right that's because
wendy's burgers are are fresh burgers
they're fresh patties hey they're fresh
they don't taste better
i mean come on they don't
i'm going to say this right now let's
let's get the debate going i'm going to
say this right now to kick things off
but i just want to go back to just can
we go back to that list of top uh
because what's happening here is of of
the of the top fast food chains
it was wendy i just want to say it was
mcdonald's starbucks this was surprising
it's surprising things there's a subway
so it's it's it's
this is a different list
see this one's saying subway's number
one there it's all go 20 yeah this is
any of these mcdonald's starbucks subway
taco bell chick-fil-a wendy's then
burger king also wendy's has outdone
burger king i always thought burger king
was in the number two spot now burger
king has kind of fallen off man but all
right so
here let me let me start us by saying
this
the big mac is the greatest burger of
all time
overrated it is
it has been attempted to have been
copied by many a place
all right i came first the big mac of
the whopper
what is wendy's equivalent
quarterback like no the big mac well
that's wendy's has to baconate well hold
on hold on but here's my point the big
mac is the greatest burger of all time
it's tried it's copied all over the
place every burger you get a special
sauce every burger you get in california
california has modeled every burger they
have after the big mac and the big mac
tastes better than any of them it tastes
better than in and out it's better than
every
1967. big mac was created in 67 the
burger went national in 68. soon became
the signature item on the menu burger
king's whopper was created in
1957. well if you were arguing burger
king that would be relevant no but that
means to me the whopper was out the
whopper was branded the whopper was a
thing for a decade a whole decade before
the big mackie map that means to me the
big mac probably had to take a signal
from the whopper yes obviously because
it's called the whopper and they said
we're going to call ours the big mac
right so i don't think that like i don't
i'm not going to give you all the
accolade the big mac is not like first
to market there they didn't plant the
flag i'm not saying they did they're
saying they're the greatest burger of
all time is the big mac
uh this is this is the wonderful thing
about mcdonald's that wendy's does not
have you got a quarter pounder with
cheese a filet-o-fish a two-cheeseburger
meal go back an apple pie
okay uh uh a mcflurry these are fun
wonderful exciting things to eat that
you can't get anywhere else besides
mcdonald's you go to wendy's now wendy's
is good i like wendy's
but it's [ __ ] you can make it home nah
you're you can make that birthday i mean
i haven't even gotten that yet make that
birthday oh come on dude even the
picture of a wendy's burger when when
okay you know i don't think you could
make a wendy's burger downstairs right
now i can't make a mcdonald's burger
burger it would never taste the way it
tastes at mcdonald's ever ever ever bro
you couldn't do it let me tell you
something right now okay you go to
wendy's you order your food they put it
they put the plastic tray in front of
you out of the box out of everything all
the display the fries the chicken
nuggets and especially the burger a
wendy's burger is soft bread fresh
lettuce and tomato onion you see the
cheese you it it plays like it looks it
looks way better off of the off as soon
as you order it and it's placed in front
of you it looks better burger king you
unwrap it out of the thing it looks like
i'm talking about burger king mcdonald's
it's late
mcdonald's is is
don't get me wrong it tastes a certain
way i there's probably some delicious
into it
what i mean now look i will give you
that mcdonald's has better breakfast
because the big donald's has the only
breakfast bacon egg and cheese biscuit
is really good
finally they pulled the head out of
their ass and they offered all day long
sausage mcmuffin with egg is the only
it's i'm not it but
i'll give you breakfast for mcdonald's i
will not give you a single burger i will
not give you any of the chicken items i
will not give nuggets the greatest
version of nuggets now i will tell you
this i will tell you the thing that
everyone has tried to copy the chicken
mcnuggets now they're made out of pink
paste they look weird and unnatural
let's delete them god bless mcdonald's
delete them i don't care a lot of people
i'm sorry but if you if you if you put
on a plate
visually and to the taste
a wendy's chicken nugget feels like a
battered piece of fried chicken that
feels way more real
mcdonald's
it is what it is i don't even criticize
the mcnugget the mcnugget is its own
thing and i'll still eat and make
nuggets it didn't but i'm telling you if
i'm going down if i'm doing blind taste
test and you're gonna give me just give
me a cheeseburger whatever fixings you
want wendy's wins it okay it's not
frozen and it's just it feels fresh it
tastes but you're missing my point i'll
tell you what everyone goes goes on
about mcdonald's fries i think they're
they're neck and neck you you shut your
mouth
you shut your mouth mcdonald's you know
what i should have done i i'll pause
this [ __ ] right now we will go down the
street we'll get we'll get a sample from
wendy's mcdonald's we'll eat it right
now live
am i also being self-serving because i
want to eat these things yes but i'll
put i will i'll let you close your eyes
you put your money where your mouth is
my my
i will never you would never be able
you would never be able to i think
they're that close i think they're that
close i think a wendy's fry and a
mcdonald's fry is so close
dude i'm telling you i'm telling you
mcdonald's fries nothing are you saying
mcdonald's burger is better than
everybody's burger
or you just stick over
stick on one thing first of all
mcdonald's fries nothing on planet earth
tastes like mcdonald's fries nothing jim
gaffigan's best joke of all time no
matter how good of a cook your mother
was did she ever make anything that
tasted as good as mcdonald's french
fries the answer is no it they they are
magical nothing you can't replicate them
you can't i believe wendy's is just as
good you're
you said comparable wendy's now wendy's
fried now let's talk about wendy's fries
yeah okay let's do it that's what we're
here for okay now let's talk about now
look at the look at the wendy's chick i
mean we're all over the charts i
understand but look at the wendy's
chicken nugget that's true it wendy's
when it hits your tray it looks pretty
much like the picture and
okay mcdonald's mcdonald's mcdonald's
takes glamour shots mcdonald's
mcdonald's never looks like the picture
looks exact that's what a big mac looks
like when you take it out of the box it
is uniform it is uniform it was created
wow look at it look at the reality
scroll down up the other way up one more
no no the other way sorry buddy stop
that's what it looks like it never looks
real it's a bad one
it does not look a bad one that's your
reality right there my friend that just
looks like exactly what you know it
looks like that's a bit okay now if you
go to a wendy's a picture of a wendy's
burger you actually like it actually
looks okay and here look at that look at
that shiny brioche bunny i don't know i
understand here's my point look at the
wendy's fried too yeah it's look at the
fries it's long it's curvy there they're
real potatoes listen to me i understand
that but you're missing my point and by
the way the flurry can i make my point
no no no no no you keep no no no the
mcflurry could take a walk
the mcflurry could take a walk
please could take a walk the frosty
sucks it tastes no it doesn't it tastes
like nutri sweet no it's chocolate
pudding
no it does not terrible no it doesn't
and i'll tell you another thing you know
people dip their they're they're not the
right they're they're the chicken nugget
and they're fry in the frosty it's so
good it's a thing yeah who else here we
go again
they're fries well we're talking about
menu
we're talking about menu wise people
everything's on their big people i just
gave you breakfast
people aren't dipping mcdonald's fries
into the mcdonald's milkshake have you
ever had a milkshake for no they're not
no they're not yes they are no they're
not that's where it's and by the way
by the way the old the old cookies that
mcdonald's the old chocolate chips and
the old
fun house cookies those were good when
we were little they don't exist anymore
and they're not anywhere near what they
were i ain't getting cookies
at mcdonald's for cookies now the frosty
is better than mcflurry the frosty is
better than ever i will now talk for 10
minutes as you just did i didn't i
didn't even touch on wendy's yet okay
touch on this is the thing chilly
oh it's disgusting okay did you ever go
to the fiction
i never really saw that is that a real
did you ever go to the ceiling is that a
real picture of wendy he's listen is
that a real picture of wendy
yeah that's her
no but that other one that other one the
redhead dave thomas yes first of all
dave thomas is a god
dave thomas is the man i mean dave
thomas i seen a guy bogarted debate so
disrespectfully in my life i mean it's
it's outrageous you're not even letting
me talk by the way and you you keep
changing the show no wendy's no more
little redheaded pigtail girl
you have a clown steering your ship a
clown
donald's fries they can't be replicated
mcdonald's cheeseburger little minced
bits of onion uh weird pickle slices
that taste like no other pickles i've
ever had you're called you take you take
the cheese off of mcdonald's burger it's
inedible you eat the patty by itself
it's inedible but you put it all
together and it becomes a thing that
tastes better than anything you've ever
had if i want listen to me i'm on the
route saying it's not good but look when
i'm on the road when i'm on the road
okay i'm not done i'm not done i'm not
done when i'm on the road okay and i go
this sucks i'm on the road i gotta i
gotta eat something decent enough and
the only fast food i go to wendy's why
because i'm like there's lettuce and
tomato on it the the potatoes the french
fries look like if i tried to make
french fries at home they still have
bits of skin on them and [ __ ] you are
literally making a case for wendy's you
are making that case
it's better food
it's better it's better food that's not
what i'm in fast food for this is the
point i'm trying to get to if i want
real food i'll go to a real restaurant
if you want real food you go to wendy's
if you want to feel weird and disgusting
after the fact that god bless you i love
mcdonald's i love it
mcdonald's knows people eat it and then
they go oh it's delicious oh i don't
know i ate mcdonald's god bless you god
bless so great after wendy's either
let's be honest i don't feel bad at the
wendy's
i don't go nuts i don't go i don't but
by the way you talked about the cheese
the bread is inedible guess what wendy's
bread actually good if you you know what
happens when you open a wendy's
cheeseburger there's a slice
a slice of american cheese on it that
you could actually hold up and put back
down i'm looking for it's not this
concoction
before i want fast food i don't want
real food wendy's is faster i want fun
when these issues wendy's is fast food
done right and if that's not their
slogan
email you know what you're probably
gonna have you probably i'll do it right
put this in right now wendy's you have
my permission to clip this and put it in
a commercial and you don't have to pay
me that much but pay me something we'll
talk about it later but don't get hung
up on the payment
wendy's is fast food done right
okay
you know what
here's the thing
i forget what i was gonna say
you don't even have chili you know why
because nobody wants machines
nobody wants chili fast chili is such a
great side that nobody else i remember
and the chili doesn't feel disgusting
there's some nice red beans in there
some nice chopped meat it has a little
kick to it it comes in chili and it
comes with the chicken go to did you
ever when they had it
imagined mcdonald's at a chili it just
looked like hold on a second by the way
i just nothing against mcdonald's
did you ever go i like wendy's by the
way i like it it's not what we're
debating i know but if mcdonald's hears
this they might be did you ever go
to the [ __ ] show they called the salad
bar wendy's did you think that was good
where they put the chili meat i don't
think that exists anymore it doesn't
anymore but it did yeah but
they put it in tomato sauce and told you
to put it on spaghetti they took the
same chili meat and put it in a vat and
told you to make tacos with it and then
they had salad it was one of the most
revolting things that ever that's ever
existed i don't know
we won't talk about mistakes we could
talk about mistakes the game the filet
of fish isn't great and the mcrib
classic i don't know what the big [ __ ]
what i don't know what the big hub is
what did you say i don't know what the
big hub is about yeah the mcrib
don't bring it back bring it back don't
bring it back i want you to say that to
my face i don't get the big hubbub about
it what was the big thing that they had
that rick and morty did was it the mcrib
bring it back the sauce no it's a
special sauce is it what was it dipping
sauce from rick and morty i don't know i
don't watch a little baby rick and morty
that did it
what recommend he's amazing
i don't watch it good good for you
my buddy created it and he's the best
and for your body hi justin i know but
it's not a baby it's it's it's dominated
um tell us about your cartoon where they
made the
joke no it was i think it was a
mcdonald's thing is what i think rick
and morty uh american morty mcdonald's
szechuan
szechuan sauce they brought it back they
helped bring it back i don't know what
you're talking about you might you owe
him you owe him a debt of gratitude you
know what szechuan sauce is and you call
yourself a fan of mcdonald's it's a
sauce that was living that they took
away that everybody hoped would bring it
back and then they helped bring it back
here's what i dip my nuggets in
uh that sounds like a actually an
euphemism yeah yeah barbecue sauce
barbecue sauce and the greatest dipping
condiment to ever exist
hot
mustard the mcdonald's hot mustard
is the greatest dipping everybody's got
the diversion no i i like a sweet and
sour from wendy's no dude dude the hot
mushrooms
forget about the sauces i'll tell you
where i have gotten burger king and i
have gotten wendy's and then i have gone
to mcdonald's and gotten hot mustard
sauce so i could dip the other stuff in
in superior this is the peek into your
life i don't really want no if you want
to reveal to people well i mean you know
you can judge all you want you can make
jokes i'm here to judge but here's what
i'm doing mcdonald's has consistently i
think
made wrong turns now making finally
realizing to make breakfast all day long
i'll give you breakfast at mcdonald's
i'll give you a tie on the fries
maybe a slight edge maybe a sandwich but
the base product is the burger and the
burgers are better at wendy's you also
have a clown god bless him it's great i
love him but a clown i don't think is
beating
wendy herself are you nuts
who are you inviting to your birthday
party clown yeah yeah exactly but who
who do i want by my side on non-birthday
days probably wendy you walk or dave
thomas you work on dave thomas is an og
god rest in peace dave thomas shout out
to dave thomas great guy great guy do
you want him as the mascot at your
birthday ray kroc listen to me who cares
about ray kroc walk into your backyard
for your birthday party i don't care if
you're 4 14 or 44 all right and you see
i'll give you all right grimace i'll get
a hamburglar ronald mcdonald actually
wait i'll tell you about a happy meal
happy meals i told you mcdonald's two
things they messed up the cookies and uh
the cookies and the animal cracker
cookies cookies i did and every once in
a while i know i used to get them they
came in
and they lose our kids okay the frosty
beats the mcflurry boom no okay i'll
give you a slight edge and fry okay okay
i'm not getting chicken i'm not tapping
into your chicken is better at wendy's
the main chicken nuggets
the burger is better at wendy's you have
better characters mcdonald's better
characters okay okay i'll give you
another one better breakfast at
mcdonald's it's it's it's it's a dead
heat by the way
why don't we put this frosty of yours up
against the hot fudge sundae at
mcdonald's because that's not the same
thing are you kidding me yes it is
that's that's
yes absolutely would be you what's going
against the frost no the frosty was an
answer to the hot fudge sundae it was
their ice cream dessert you eat it with
a spoon
the frosty's chocolate and the [ __ ]
hot fudge sundae is vanilla with hot
fudge on it which you should like better
by the way so what do you have to say
they also have a vanilla frosty oh uh
don't even let me tell you something
right now another thing the uh happy
meal
i gotta give it to them they always had
it growing up now they abandoned the
happy meal the happy meal is pitiful now
like the happy meal doesn't come in that
little freaking
with the m as the handles in that box
and then the toys took a hit yeah i
don't know why because people like you
started going into mcdonald's and saying
i want this to be more like a real
restaurant you that wasn't me
that wasn't me okay that was started
complaining but you want to do salads
yes better salads though no you're nuts
are you crazy
and that's great but the salad itself
i'm not sucking down a bag of chocolate
my god i crave the mcdonald's salads i
get the grilled chicken and i get the
poultry you have
they got you by the cajons pal you crave
mcdonald's salad who says that i do i do
i say it a lot of people about
apparently uh everybody in the country
here's what should have happened here's
what should have happened for this
episode here's what should have happened
we should have bought one of everything
head to head we should have had it right
on this table and we should have took a
bite each and been really honest with
each other really honest because if we
did that i'm telling you right now
wendy's would you like mark it down part
two we will we will do we will do it
we're over okay okay but but let me ask
you this though we're doing this
regardless of the score
yeah
yes i think we get a cheeseburger versus
cheeseburger fried versus fry a frosty
versus mcflurry chicken versus chicken
nugget a salad versus salad and so on
and so forth thank you for explaining to
me what it meant to get one of each
steak and then compare it i understood
what it meant
well i believe if we had that in front
of us you would go down like a house of
cards let's let's do it
second episode i'm not pulling punches
i'm giving you breakfast i'm giving you
characters i'm giving you a slight edge
on the front give me anything okay what
i'm saying to you is this mcdonald's
creates a met before you look at it
mcdonald's me creates a magical food you
can't get anywhere else and that's why i
think it's the best sometimes i feel
sick after eating mcdonald's i do not
really feel sick after eating one but i
could replicate wendy's in your kitchen
right now we could go to the market you
oh yes i could can't oh yes i could you
can't you want to bet me that i could
replicate wendy's but you can't
replicate mcdonald's i can't i've tried
both you know why because wendy's tastes
more like a genuine cheeseburger
mcdonald's is its own caterpillar
genuine cheeseburger to denny's i don't
give a [ __ ]
shut them out
and i'll say this i'll say this in
closing the g you want to talk about
genius you know why mcdonald's food is
the way it is so anybody at any age can
eat it do you ever notice you don't need
teeth to eat it you could pull it apart
with your tongue
you are not making a case for mcdonald's
everybody from you say you could eat
mcdonald's with your tongue yeah
everybody from a two-year-old
thank you for your parting words you
know why mcdonald's is great because
it's so just it's the conversation that
you can eat it with your tongue
i said i said
i said wendy's quality ingredients done
right what did i say what was it fast
food done right wendy's fast food done
right i leave you with that joe derosa
says mcdonald's you don't need teeth to
eat it
[Music]
you don't need teeth to eat anybody at
any age can eat mcdonald's and enjoy it
it is there for i can't believe that
that is your slogan though that's your
party words that's all you need to know
we could have saved everyone 35 minutes
go to the phones by the way have you
ever had a hot apple pie for mcdonald's
you think wendy says anything that can
come
close to that thing you're nuts all
right it's time for the humble pie
segment humble pie here we go all right
someone's gonna eat some humble pie
right now we're checking the twitter
polls
we should start having mike reveal it on
the screen so we see it at the same time
let's do it
let's do it wait wait my mike has to
vote no no mike don't vote no he has to
in order to see the answer
oh okay
oh
come on baby come on baby
oh my god and it was handily it was
handily and mcdonald's is
number one in every way in every
category and every year they were the
favorite on paper they were the favorite
at the casino
12
200 votes wendy's wins
58.4 percent to 41.6 that's a handy
victory though that's it i'd say more
than five percent is a little bit tight
but that is margin i mean that's
approaching 60 40 bro
i mean it is it is when mcdonald's is a
powerhouse favorite yes it is okay yes
it is i believe that is all right all
right i believe that is now you went
into this saying and i i gave you baby
yeah i gave wendy's credit took one back
from you i gave wendy's credit at the
beginning and i said i think they could
win this i said that did i not say that
and the reason that i don't think burger
king would have won the reason that i
said that of course burger king wouldn't
win people
people like wendy's because this country
is becoming weaker by the second and
everybody needs everything to be instant
and healthy okay that's why there's a
panero bread everywhere you go god now
now you're making a case for health
there's no you're making a case that
wendy's is healthy there's no fun
there's no fun now you're just throwing
out now now you're just now you're
spiraling
you're spiraling wendy's is healthy
mcdonald's is fun all right let's read
the tweets
come on baby you guys we're on the same
page and i also think that's five to
three now five to three and you lost
today i want to tell you something about
you i want to tell you what you're
saying okay
and here she is to you
i can't choose rewards listen to me i
still love you i i love you too okay
cheers man i'd like to choose water oh
that's crazy
it is what it is
let me tell you something about you
today
okay
today we had okay just
today you lost
let me tell you something i don't know
if we want to reveal this but we do a
couple episodes in a row well either
they know that because we're wearing the
same clothes in all of them
i could i can't wash this and wear it in
a couple weeks
uh today you lost
you didn't talk like it and mcdonald's
you claim that vanilla was the
powerhouse in ice cream and i proved it
well yeah but i'm saying you never
thought vanilla wasn't the powerhouse
well i thought by popular opinion that
vanilla had the uphill battle again we
should name what we think of the betting
odds in the beginning because i think
chocolate had the betting odds over
vanilla and vanilla one i think
mcdonald's had the betting odds of
wendy's and wendy's one but i can tell
you right now this this i thought i
might be able to pull it off this
surprised me even this surprised me you
know what it is it's just it's just and
there's nothing against mcdonald's this
is the thing we have to say that but you
just because i don't want to alienate i
don't run out but you can keep knocking
them because because here's the thing
when we're talking apple juice oranges
we're not applying a brand to it you
know so i don't want to just be like you
know [ __ ] on the whole point here is to
celebrate the good parts of it and not
the good parts of it and you know like
so just you know and it is what it is it
just is what it is
would have one mcdonald's would have won
this is we asked the hard-hitting
questions here okay so let's go to the
let's go to the tweets let's read some
of the replies the fact that wendy's is
winning by that much is an atrocity i
like wendy's as much as the next person
but it has nothing on the golden arches
i couldn't agree more
plus nothing beats an eminem mcflurry
uh brian redman writes come on those
picking mcdonald's are all
are all from dr what the hell are all
from drool hitting their phones by
mistake while thinking of wendy's i i
think that's how he wrote that come on
those freaking dolls are all from julian
their phones by mistake while thinking
of wendy's he's for wendy's okay yeah
yeah
uh hey brian
mcdonald's hi brian mcdonald's for
breakfast and wendy's for everything
else
oh my god pringles has a baconator
flavor now with wendy's disgraceful
uh
i love them all the wendy's beef even
beats in and out i don't know why those
sheep are willing to wait an hour long
line for in and out i'm also glad to
have the choice of chili and a baked
potato which i am so sorry that i didn't
bring up
baked potatoes this is the and then by
the way that's not new baked potato has
been around forever with wendy's
chili has been around forever when it's
and they do it right you're not getting
a baked potato at mcdonald's potatoes
good but you're missing my point when i
want something that resembles real food
i will go to wendy's quickly when i want
fun fast food i will go to mcdonald's
why is why is it mcdonald's fun because
it's a treat remember when you were a
kid and you got mcdonald's and it tasted
like you're associated
but let me say this let me say this with
pizza hut too when you were a kid you
would get it and it tasted like nothing
you could get anywhere else ever there
was a difference between pizza hut and
the pizzeria and that's why you wanted
pizza hut sometimes that's what
mcdonald's is when you got mcdonald's as
a kid you didn't say i like it because
it tastes like my mom's hamburger or it
tastes homemade sure you could eat it
with no tea i heard it cartoon food
it tastes like cartoon food i get that i
don't disagree with it i don't not like
mcdonald's i keep doing double negatives
i like mcdonald's but you asked me
mcdonald's wendy's i'm going wendy's
okay okay mcdonald's okay let's read
some let's read some of the two go ahead
go ahead rub salt in the wound now
they both suck astronomically but i
gotta say mcdonald's then
okay i've worked at mcdonald's before it
wasn't long but trust me it's wendy's
for sure you'd want to step foot in the
mcdonald's i worked at okay well you
know that's not every mcdonald's the
only thing for mcdonald's i prefer are
there mcnuggets
by the way have become just the name for
chicken nuggets everywhere nobody ever
goes i want chicken nuggets everybody
calls it ubiquity to it because they
invented the form
respect the the force okay here we go
ready
chicken nuggets wendy's chicken
sandwiches wendy's chilean baked potato
option wendy's burgers mcds fries mcds
breakfast food mcds too close to me love
them both just depends on what i'm in
the mood for wendy's better chicken
nuggets and they're spicy now they have
spicy chicken sandwiches their burgers
are overall better and they have
frosties
frosties i i'm gonna nominate this
person for winter i just wish wendy's
would wash their potatoes better they
shouldn't still taste like dirt
[Laughter]
i i don't know what she's talking about
for me wendy's used to be better for me
when did you see it every time i get
wendy's their service is slow come on i
told my service come on
overall meals and burgers and salads
wendy's takes it but when it comes to
the fries nobody can overtake mcdonald's
well we're talking about overalls
wendy's but they both promote explosive
diarrhea
all these people picked wendy's to fit
in with a trend what trend
wendy's bigger burgers but mcdonald's
fries gave the edge to me trend is the
trend is wendy's trolling other places
everybody likes wendy's right now
because they talk all this [ __ ] and it's
really funny
but the king is the king the queen is
the queen and and mcdonald's uh wears
home style chicken sandwich which i also
didn't mention and dave's double nothing
compares i agree jim sal is trying to
divide the nation
uh
wendy's always adds too much salt in
their fries uh that happens from time to
time taste buds day wendy's heart says
mcdonald's oh taste buds say okay
it's still tied both oh it was tied at
one point oh there's a breakfast
baconator which i didn't even know about
i don't even think i did wendy's justice
although we got a w wendy's fries are
piss-poor that by itself is a
disqualifier
all right we gotta pick a winner here
i'm gonna go with the dirt lady
let's see
anyone that doesn't say mcdonald's is
incapable of love
okay i would say that's in the running
which one do you want the potatoes taste
like turret or the mcdonald's is
incapable of love
one
i think that mcdonald's is incapable of
love is
is a little wittier wendy's has better
quality food mcdonald's has less quality
but more affordable prices i don't want
to talk but i find that very funny they
shouldn't still taste like dirt makes me
i in all caps i accidentally voted
mcdonald's no
all right let's give it to that one okay
where is it on the list uh it's by silly
ally
at s-i-l-l-y-a-l-l-y-y-y
i accidentally voted mcdonald's new okay
thank you silly ally
oh folks that was ooh that was a good
one and you thought we we we started
that one you were like i don't think i
didn't know yeah i don't know i don't
even think i did wendy's justice really
i was because there's so many uh menu
items i didn't bother to name but that's
just because i was so caught up we only
have usually like 30 30 40 minutes
whatever it is
um but
yeah that was a i mean that was a big
upset dude oh you're having big upsets
yeah yeah you covered wendy's it's just
the menu items aren't very memorable so
you know it's hard to call them to mine
you know
anyway uh
[Laughter]
feel good right now i feel good too i
love wendy's i love mcdonald's i think
mcdonald's is king but i do love wendy's
uh and that's not being diplomatic and
in fact we talked about going down the
street after this to get some of this
and i am torn as to i kind of want to
get a little something from each place
wendy's is mine
huh i love wendy's i love mcdonald's i
like win i love wendy's i don't feel as
guilty coming away from a wendy's as i
do coming away from mcdonald's this is
what i keep saying
this is what if i want to feel guilty
like it's
don't get me wrong it's a great guilty
pleasure they both are but like you know
fast food in general is a guilty
pleasure you know what it is this is my
point
mcdonald's is a snickers bar
all right wendy's is a toblerone
yeah it's better quality and everything
but when you want to i need to i need to
have a moment with that when you want a
candy bar you're like give me a
snickers bar give me the thing that is
so different i think a [ __ ] like a shake
shack to toblerone
but do you see what i'm saying you see
what i'm saying yeah you go you go oh
it's a yeah it's gone no i don't i what
i think you're saying is i think you're
making a case for wendy's because i
think they're the exact same yet you
somehow keep equating wendy's with
better quality but they're the exact
same the same freaking shape of place
they have a drive-through they're open
the same hours they have the same price
range they basically have the same menu
items and you keep saying that wendy's
is some place you go when you don't want
cartoon food when you need teeth to eat
and i and i think all you're doing is
proving the fact that as similar as they
are wendy's is set apartments instead
they are both fast nothing against
mcdonald's mcdonald's i shed there bad
both fast food restaurants
but wendy's is the one i go to when i
want to get something that's a little
more dinner-like and mcdonald's is more
fun for me it's like going to a movie
theater and bringing your own fruit
versus getting the sour patch kids you
want the sour patch kids
beep this but what the [ __ ] was that
analogy
the analogy is quality food is quality
food i get that but sometimes you don't
want quality food sometimes you want fun
crazy food that's terrible for you
because it's different than anything
else you could ever get the poll was
better food
better faster donald's mcdonald's
it's better fast food all right whatever
all right well babe the polls are close
i know i know they're closed i know
they're closed and you've got five and i
only one favorite just hit me up with a
refresh on apple orange
just see where we're at apple orange
can we hit it 30.
oh my god you son of a [ __ ] you son of
a [ __ ] i know this is from last week's
episode but we are at 37
400 votes that's our show folks all
right uh
uh if you want to hear more of me
corrine fisher and i have a podcast
called without a country we discuss the
news uh it is on the gas digital network
if you want to subscribe to that network
you can use the code wac get a free
month's uh trial uh and access to all of
their content uh and then also pat walsh
and i have a podcast called we'll see
you in hell where we review movies uh
new episodes only on patreon.com
wsyih podcast and uh the back catalog is
available everywhere else uh
salvolcanocounty.com
for if and when i tour again actually
the tenderloins.com because i think that
our our tour is rescheduled for next
year although you know it'll be pending
the world status um and then uh yeah i
mean you know the shows are on and
everything and i hope you're watching
them um true and tbs uh but i want to
promote uh my podcast with christa
stefano called hey babe and uh yeah
that's it i really feel good about where
i'm going where the momentum is going
with this podcast i'm having fun we're
loving this with you guys by the way
yeah um this is such an interactive fun
podcast that like we are having an
absolute blast with this we hope you
guys are enjoying it too
uh yeah actually and thank you hey for
those people that got the taste bud
tattoos thank you
[Laughter]
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
taste buds if you don't want your purse
they'll take your pay stubs
taste buds
taste buds better put on your boots make
sure they're laced up what does that
have to do with it
[Music]
you